vous savez que matthieu delormeau avait
fait une couleur on lui avait promis à
8,33 matthieu delormeau et benoît venez
moi je venais la donner et donner
mathieu vous ne vous êtes pas allé alors
un droit s'est occupé de votre couleur
vous vouliez à 8,33 j'ai juste fait la
base il manque la mèche à mèche d'accord
très honorifique 1,7 1,8 hongrois dont
c'est un blu un blond vénitien
ah non pas du tout voilà californien
california d'accord qu'est ce que c'est
que sa lancée de la lacc parce que
j'aimerais bien peaufiné d'accord vous
voulez vos fines et alors il ne va pas
devoir tout de suite d'accord
est ce que vous voulez alors d'abord je
ne veux pas que mathieu se voit enlever
tout parce que vous allez avoir la
surprise je pense que je vois il ya du
bon samaritain céderait de bienvenue
aller à celui-ci ça fait ressortir si
j'ai fait confiance 1 alors les chéris
couper tous les retours s'il vous plaît
et si vous pouvez remercier pouvez vous
qualifier au plus verser les attentions
alors vous allez donc mes chéris ouais
vous allez refaire donc la coiffure de
mathieu oui bien sûr j'ai à travailler
au doigt un peu là stylisé d'accord on
les a utilisés
c'est parti
est ce qu'il y a qu'est ce qu'il ya à
temps mais mai à bâle mais jamais c'est
juste un vrai sens des gestes pas
coiffée et justin base et les règles
éthiques
je mets ce qu est ce qu on entamait sa
mèche c'est dans sunshine bien sûr super
sentai je ferai tout ce que tu veux tu
en voilà du sunshine
ouais semag régine non mais mais pas les
toi tu che artistes capillaire
alors on va hyper bien ou mathieu
matière bien je vous jure c'est ma
gueule à wipro de m haies en pâte en
vacances en thaïlande
oui s'il vous plaît vous partez en
vacances en thaïlande oui ça va plaire
aux thaïlande elle ça mais moi j'ai
qu'une question c'est est-ce que ça vous
plaît ah ouais et n'oubliez pas que
c'est pas terminé il a fait la base de
blond j'adorerais faire du mèche à mèche
ans il dort sunshine juste après après
l'émission il va peaufiner parce que
dans mon cas d'accord le tri ont été les
meilleurs ce que je propose c'est qu'on
va remettre la serviette d'accord et
vous allez-vous découvrir derrière le
miroir vous allez nous dire ce que vous
en pensez
moi je trouve ça magnifique bam écrase
tout merci est resté seul mois de
janvier
d'accord mais les la motion non mais je
vais rire m'inquiète qui n'a pas fait
une connerie tu me mets tu vas bien
écouter idiot regardez les côtés ils
sont vie les nigauds lui attention
mathieu mathieu et je vous jure juste
petit honte à toi ou trouvez que ça lui
va bien jouer face à lula sont en valeur
deux batteurs ça très chaud flottant
moderne
ces moteurs
zoug a ajouté mme hodder c'est le terme
aulas est où là
non mais franchement c'est beau je suis
une vraie couleur faut tout recommencer
mais non c'est très beau je vous jure
que c'est vrai elle a fait ressortir tes
violemment vous trouvez voilà mais je
tombe tout le temps un piège dans le
camp alors c'est vrai sur nrj 12 ans
maintenant mais franchement c'est ma
maman je mesure tout à se trouve ça
super beau je trouve très très beau mais
vous asseoir
benoît benoît quoi qu'est dégueulasse et
de lui avoir fait remplir le jeu reste à
des 8 mathieu chouchane et je vous jure
que c'est là qu'on va très bien
est ce que ça vous va vers du soutien
sur twitter http chauve et aubergines
garde s'il vous plaît les chéris c'est
très réussi bravo mathieu je vous le dis
mon mathieu bravo et benoît benoît est
ce que ce que ça s'en va maintenant
c'est permanent qui m'a dit faire une
permanente non alors sans rigoler non
non ça s'en va passer une couleur
permanente
non ils sont charriées comment il s'en
charrier les vraies couleurs et ammoniac
et tous et oui c'est tout c'est très
cool rcd permanent ça reste les pouces
il pousse en moyenne les miens d'un
centimètre et demi par mois
là il m'a fait quoi là j'ai de moi je
vous le jure m'a tuer que je vous trouve
magnifique à midi mais il faut encore
faire une couleur dans combien de temps
maintenant il faut laisser reposer le
cheveu cinéma péter au bac il va être
chaud donc qu'est ce que vous voulez
gomis montrouge à vous choisirez vous
savez bigou les fusées légalement mais
oui lemon l'adoption je vous jure que ça
vous va super bien
si je vous jure les filles franchement
va faire un carton
il faut voir le public arabe chaïma pas
dégueu rock star avec main avec le cuir
rouge de la summer savall et après
qu'est ce qui se passe car le pubis
maintenant demain je déjeune avec mon
père qui est avocat et je déjeune avec
lui juste en bas de son cabinet
d'avocats new line sur la james mais
voilà bonjour je vous aime matthieu
delormeau
voilà je vous le dis pas qu'elle vous
astrazeneca mais si vraiment vous êtes
un génie
bravo merci viol est très fort
on va continuer cette émission est là on
a une surprise magnifique pour je sais à
quoi vous ressemblez voix super bien en
quoi une allumette fou je vous jure que
c'est vrai pour une fois vous allez
pouvoir m'allumer
vous créez pas si bien dire quoi vous
avez promis que quand je donnerai ma
réponse quelle qu'elle soit
il y aurait un bisou à bisous
ça va aller on verra ça plus tard et
tout ça non on va lever ma décision et
je suis rouge
j'ai vu de plus je vous jure mathieu que
vous avez la chance d'avoir un visage
parfait et des yeux parfait un corps
parfait donc savoure a extrêmement bien
joué a remercié bercy benoît kate avait
converti bonaparte il a eu peur